[Music]
on this saturday night russian retreat
evidence soldiers are pulling out of
kiev but regrouping in other regions
still at risk and in a rare move the
pope pushes back with harsh words aimed
at vladimir putin
history delivered today the people have
spoken amazon workers vote to unionize
scientists worry sleeping craters could
re-awaken there's clearly something
going on and what a massive tsunami of
rocks and mud is teaching us about
climate change
global national
reporting tonight
chris galas
good evening and thanks for joining us
following weeks of constant bombardment
the outskirts of kiev have gone quiet as
ukrainian forces retake territory around
the country's capital what's left though
is utter devastation burned out military
vehicles on residential blocks homes
destroyed and reports of the bodies of
civilians littering the streets the
latest intelligence suggests russian
forces are withdrawing from the capital
and in the country's north but the
fighting continues to intensify in the
east abigail beeman has the latest but
first a warning some of the images in
her story are disturbing
russia's retreat around keeve marked by
bodies strewn along the road others in
mass graves
ukraine's president says its troops have
retaken control of more than 30 towns or
villages but warns russia is leaving
mines behind us traps warning people to
be careful his forces haven't made any
advances
in the past several weeks
there are logistical problems
there is clearly a problem with morale
within his own forces
equipment is failing while in the east
zalenski says russian troops are
advancing on donbass and harkev and the
situation remains extremely difficult
whatever russian narratives are
are on those negotiations or so-called
peace talks we have to understand
russia will not stop if it's not stopped
also in the east the serious challenge
of getting humanitarian aid into
mariopol and melitopol and getting
people out after other vehicles were
forced to turn back this convoy
successfully rescued these people on a
12-hour journey away from the besieged
port city
not enough space says the driver with so
many people who wanted to leave some had
to stand others of course remain trapped
the red cross is making more attempts to
get through the targeting of civilians
really is i mean it's a war crime it's
barbaric it's savage
and i think the western world has to
take greater action right now to make
sure that those corridors remain open
and that the refugees who are fleeing
marijual are safe
saturday pope francis came the closest
yet to criticizing russian president
vladimir putin for provoking and
fomenting conflicts though not by name
he also said a papal visit to kiev is on
the table
here in canada foreign minister melanie
jo lee gears up for a week-long trip to
europe to discuss the war in ukraine
with allies she begins with a meeting
with her counterpart in finland monday
then on to berlin and finally meetings
with g7 and nato foreign ministers in
brussels abigail beeman global news
ottawa
this chaotic scene playing out in
southern ukraine after a pro-ukrainian
rally was reportedly dispersed by
russian forces local officials say stun
grenades were used after residents
gathered in the center of the occupied
town some participants are said to have
been detained
ukraine says it's run out of the initial
rounds of ammunition canada sent the
country in february and needs more the
canadian government is considering the
request but it will come at a cost to
our military mercedes stephenson joins
us now with more mercedes
chris global news has learned that the
ukrainian government has sent ottawa a
formal letter asking for more anti-tank
rounds to fight the russians
sources say heavy fighting has rapidly
depleted or is about to consume the
entire supply of 2 000 rounds that
canada initially sent the rounds are
fired out of a canadian provided
recoilless rifle system known as the
carl gustav
one thousand more rounds are being
considered something a government source
told global news is expected to be
approved and delivered to the ukrainians
but the additional rounds will come at a
cost they're being shared out of
canada's own limited war chest unlike
the previous ones which were pulled from
a surplus stockpile that was intended
for allies
canada already has extremely limited
anti-tank capabilities and military
sources say even though the government
appears committed to restocking supplies
it could take years to replace the
rounds highlighting the long-term
neglect of army combat capabilities all
of this puts a focus on the upcoming
federal budget scheduled for thursday
where the government has hinted we could
expect significantly increased defense
spending
another option for canada to support
ukraine providing money for the
ukrainian government to purchase their
own weapons that's something ukrainian
mps who were here in ottawa asked prime
minister justin trudeau for on friday
i spoke to the chair of the delegation
lisia
about what's at stake
but we would like to highlight that it's
not a war between russia and ukraine
it's a war between evil and democratic
world
so we have to win and i'm sure that with
the canadian support
ukraine will be a symbol of victory
in this struggle government sources
couldn't tell us when ukraine could
expect more weapons support but it does
sound like it's coming in some form
chris mercedes stephenson in ottawa
thanks mercedes and you can catch the
full interview tomorrow on the west
block
right here on global
in the u.s workers at one of amazon's
warehouses on staten island in new york
voted to unionize the first time that's
happened in the company's 27-year
history owned by billionaire jeff bezos
the company has spent millions to stop
the union from forming but as jennifer
johnson reports workers say it's just
the beginning for amazon employees
across the u.s and canada
a champagne bottle was popped as amazon
workers in new york cheered on their
historic vote for the first time in
almost three decades employees at one
facility voted to unionize this is the
cap the catalyst for the revolution um
just like starbucks y'all see what's
going on with the starbucks unionizing
across the country the boat was led by
former amazon employee christian smalls
who was fired in 2020 over alleged
safety issues but it came after smalls
helped organize a walkout over
insufficient covenanting precautions
small says workers at 18 other amazon
facilities may follow their lead a vote
to unionize at an alabama facility
failed last year but a recount was taken
with results expected this week we go on
fight to the very end and i'm confident
that this won't be the last unionization
for amazon
and it's not just in america the
teamsters union has launched organizing
drives in at least nine of amazon's 14
facilities in canada many of the
country's 25 thousand amazon employees
are angry over what they say were unsafe
working conditions during the pandemic i
think we're going to see
more and more union activity workers do
have the upper hand right now the vote
came as a congressional committee
launches an investigation into amazon's
labor practices congress wants answers
after tornadoes killed six amazon
workers last year in illinois employees
say they were told they couldn't leave
to find shelter the white house weighed
in the president was glad to see workers
ensure their voices are heard with
respect to important workplace decisions
congress is also investigating why
amazon employees were allegedly told to
stay on the job during deadly wildfires
in california extreme heat last summer
in the pacific northwest
and two hurricanes in 2017 and 2021. now
thousands of amazon workers are ready to
take on the world's largest online
retailer energized by this first
successful vote
jennifer johnson global news washington
officials in newfoundland and labrador
admit there have been more data theft
stemming from a vicious cyber attack
last fall hackers targeted the
province's health care networks at a
time when hospitals were already
buckling under the stress of the
pandemic and as ross lord reports there
are fears governments will increasingly
be targeted
five months after the newfoundland and
labrador healthcare system was
devastated by what some analysts called
the worst cyber attack in canadian
history it turns out hackers stole even
more sensitive information than first
believed over two hundred thousand files
were taken from a network drive at
eastern health's it
environment
and a portion of that
may contain patient information and
employee information a disturbing
development for the province and for
national agencies the rcmp are involved
and we have spoken with the federal
agencies such as but not limited to the
canadian centre for cyber security cyber
security analysts say it's critical for
governments and businesses all over
canada to be on guard especially
considering the influence of russian
sourced tech crimes i would assume there
will be retaliation for the fact that
canada has been very vocal
when it comes to supporting the ukraine
and certainly uh supporting all of the
sanctions against russia more need than
ever he says for everyone online to use
stronger passwords multi-factor
authentication and updated software to
keep hackers out
in a statement canada's communications
security establishment says it has
unique tools in place to monitor detect
and investigate potential threats
back in newfoundland and labrador the
government refuses to say who is
responsible it says there are no
indications of stolen identities or
pilfered bank accounts we have
identified things that we are rectifying
the nature of those
is
is confidential for reasons of security
so we won't be talking about that in a
public arena after widespread delays and
surgeries and even cancer treatments
health officials say the province's
system is almost back to normal although
it could take another month or two to
confirm how many thousands of patients
and staff have had their personal
information stolen
ross lord global news
in ontario pandemic related
hospitalizations are on the rise today
the province reported 855 people in
hospital because of covid19 that's 50
more than yesterday there are more than
3 thousand new cases today but ontario's
top doctor says the actual number is
likely 10 times higher because of
limited pcr testing
the first cruise ship scheduled to sail
into a canadian port since the pandemic
began has already halted its voyage
because of a covid outbreak the
caribbean princess is currently docked
in san francisco it was due to anchor in
victoria on wednesday carrying on to
vancouver from there but princess cruise
line says its 600 passengers are
receiving refunds and they're all flying
home coming up escape from harkev
families leaving everything behind and
the volunteers helping them survive
and australia's battered beaches the
wicked storm hitting the sydney
coastline
[Music]
the head of russia's space agency says
it will end cooperation with western
countries on the international space
station until sanctions are lifted
dmitry rogozin didn't include a timeline
for ending russia's involvement in the
space project he has previously said
sanctions could destroy the u.s russian
partnership on the iss
nasa officials say the partnership is
continuing as normal for now right now
there are seven crew members on the
space station including three russians
harkiv the second largest city in
ukraine is one of the most intense
battlegrounds since russia invaded in
february the city has remained in
ukrainian control but it's been battered
by relentless airstrikes and shelling by
russian forces this week for the new
reality christa hesse reports on one
man's heroic effort to bring people out
safely and replenish critical supplies
for families trapped in the war zone
here's an excerpt
roman tropin makes the two and a half
hour drive from dinipra to harcav a few
times a week carrying with him much
needed medical supplies and food
there's a big problem lack of children's
food diapers
we pass it to volunteer centers and
hospitals and heartgive
and from there we evacuate people a lot
of civilians who cannot leave heart give
by themselves and we are helping them
with most stores and services shuttered
the supplies brought in from out of town
have become a lifeline for people
trapped in arkiv
this school has been turned into an
emergency supply center
to sit and wait watching how russians
are killing our people
this is kind of impossible
we are trying to help as much as we can
he along with 20 or so friends banded
together to deliver humanitarian aid to
harkiv and other hard-hit regions even
paying for gas and supplies out of their
own pocket strasbourg
[Music]
now we are going back to the meeting
point to pick up evacuees from harcav to
dinipra
there he meets two families eager to
remove their children from the war zone
igenya koslova and her two daughters
spent 10 days underground in a bomb
shelter before finally finding a ride
out of the city she is not
to be honest it's scary very scary she
says because where we were houses were
shelled people were left homeless
everything was ruined
now they head west uncertain of what
lies ahead for them among many
ukrainians there's a sense of
bewilderment
while many thought a conflict with
russia could indeed happen
in harkiv the reality is far worse than
anything they could have imagined
and you can catch chris tahesey's full
report on the escape from harkiv tonight
on the new reality that's at 8 pm right
here on global
up next the giant tsunami nobody saw and
why it's a warning about the impacts of
climate change
wild weather whips up monster waves down
under swallowing up some of sydney's
busiest beaches the storm causing
treacherous conditions along the new
south wales coastline
wind gusts clocking 50 kilometers an
hour coupled with king tides pumped up
powerful 10 meter swells that pounded
the shoreline in bondi and bronte
damaging sea walls and surf clubs
well no one saw a massive landslide in a
remote valley on bc central coast back
in late 2020 but it was detected as far
away as australia in a few seconds 50
million tons of rock dropped from a
mountainside into elliott lake and the
results of a new study show it triggered
a tsunami a hundred meters tall
as ted chernecki reports researchers
fear it's a red flag for any region
where glaciers are melting
it was a helicopter pilot who first
spotted the carnage a mass of rocks and
boulders had crashed into the elliott
creek glacial lake creating a 100 meter
high tsunami
and now a new study has some startling
findings one was how fast that wave was
moving we're talking 180 kilometers an
hour
by the time the the landslide hit the
lake scientists were able to create an
animation of what happened on november
28 2020. luckily no one was in the area
because no one could have outrun a
flooding event that was over in a matter
of minutes a 100 meter tsunami is almost
as tall as the highest span on the
lion's gate bridge you know the terrain
is much much steeper much tighter and so
there's really only so much horizontal
motion that can happen and that water
really has nowhere to go but up
the reason they were able to replicate
what happened so accurately is because
glaciers in central bc are melting
faster than almost anywhere else in the
world the modeling also showed how far
downstream the flooding occurred more
than 11 kilometers destroying salmon
spawning stream beds the reports
suggesting this should be a wake-up call
as glaciers melt they leave unstable
rock literally hanging in the air and in
some cases it just needs a little push
to make it let go november 2020 was
unusually wet
precipitation in some cases is that
important trigger for many of these
events it's not always the
the trigger and we still don't know the
exact
uh straw that broke the camel's back in
many ways we were lucky a that no one
was hurt and b that the glacier had been
so well studied prior to the slide but
block can only go so far and scientists
are now looking closer at all melting
glaciers especially those with shoreline
communities within striking distance of
the next tsunami
ted shernick global news
still ahead the seismic swarm hitting an
island paradise why residents there are
getting very nervous
[Music]
people in the azores are used to seismic
activity but there's nothing normal
about what's going on there right now
over the past couple of weeks
one of the islands has been hit by more
than twenty thousand little earthquakes
the azores are a set of nine islands in
the mid-atlantic they're part of
portugal located about 1400 kilometers
west of lisbon and as mike armstrong
explains people are bracing for what
might come next
in the azores right now they're
basically watching anything that can be
watched
they're sensors that measure shaking but
these are probes measuring gases
this volcanologist says they're looking
for components of sulfur trying to
understand what's going on with the
volcanic system below
now the azores have an alert system for
volcanoes it was raised to a four this
week its second highest level the island
of sao jorge has been hit by something
called a seismic swarm there have been
literally thousands of small earthquakes
only measuring up to a magnitude 3.3
most of them aren't strong enough to be
felt by people except emotionally
i'm scared to death this woman says not
just for myself but for everyone who
lives on the island it's hard
well the island has five volcano craters
but it hasn't had an eruption in more
than 200 years the last one was in 1808.
well with all the seismic activity
experts say something could be coming
authorities have started moving people
with limited mobility off the island
suspended classes at some schools
and set up a camp in case homes have to
be evacuated
the soldier says the camp is support for
the population in the event of a
catastrophe that they hope doesn't
happen expressions
there's clearly something going on
canadian volcanologist melanie kellman
says the challenge for experts is trying
to figure out what's going on deep into
the earth with nothing but measurements
from the surface what they try to do she
says is look at other places where
similar events have happened and try to
predict the same thing might happen
again
in case of the azores this is what many
are pointing to spain's la palma volcano
last year was preceded by a similar
seismic swarm in that case it led to a
fissure eruption that lasted 85 days
kelman says with the azores there are
similar precursors and there is good
reason to monitor it closely it may lead
to an eruption it may not obviously
there's i think a justification for for
a heightened alert just because we don't
know what will happen
so far more than 1500 people have left
the island that's about a sixth of the
population in the case of this couple
they took a precaution with the taxi
driver who took them to the airport
he says they asked the driver to take a
picture of them in front of their house
because they don't know what it might
look like when they go back
people are
on edge
mike armstrong global news
and that is global national for this
saturday night i'm chris galas
tonight we'll leave you in vancouver
where the city's cherry blossoms are in
full bloom a welcome sight for weary
canadians have a great night see you
tomorrow
[Applause]
[Music]
you